the voice le programme doit-il revenir
vraiment l'année prochaine samedi sur
tf1 c'est la finale de the voice et ont
dit ces programmes est arrivé en tête
des zones ans 5,4 millions de
téléspectateurs nicolas pernikoff et 9
ans cassandra de france 3 c'était une
rediffusion sur france 3 ouais mais par
contre c'est un énorme au score puisque
depuis 2016 n'avaient pas atteint tous
ces salons d'audience moi je pense que
c'est vianney y est pour beaucoup aussi
de nuit vraiment alors on va revoir la
gagnante ses marges
coachés par florent pagny florent pagny
qui viennent souvent way a remporté
cette dixième saison a devancé jean
bauer qui était pourtant le grand favori
de cette édition à 100 récoltons 68 % du
public
regardez sa prestation plus sa victoire
regarde
[Musique]
[Rires]
non
[Musique]
mais
et de voice 2021 marqué avec 68% de vos
suffrages
bravo margueray votre iphone car oui oui
teddy
moi je pense que c'est son duo avec
london grammar qui a tout fait basculer
ses marges et parce que c'est
exceptionnel mais on n'a pas vraiment
l'impression qu'elle faisait partie du
groupe et elle a été merveilleux c'est
donc le film alors oui oui avec un aride
de tu as raison en revanche vous dire la
chanter mon vieux j'ai trouvé une cata
ce catastrophe la tâche on est d'accord
mais cela donne moi je suis pas du tout
d'accord qu'elle ait gagné c'est un
milady de cassandra poudrier c'était un
mini dit oui merci maintenant on s'en
fout alors oui non alors je suis à mon
dieu c'est moi aussi j'adore cette
chance mais moi aussi ce qu'il appelait
pas des munzaya pelé daniel vischer
parce que c'était trop dur formes en 2d
dans l'émotion ne voyait pas d'émotions
et vous êtes chanteur vous peut-être les
faire gagner
ouais là pour gagner mais aussi chez le
duo si l audio est bien aussi quand même
parce que même si ça qui n'avait pas
démérité franchement c'était une diva la
main talent monstrueux sers-toi faire un
duo avec grand corps malade qui est un
très beau duo quand vous chantez avec ce
groupe forcément vous partez grammaire
c'est bien servir puisse allah l'ancien
sait très bien que les gagner mais ça
sert plus à rien guindée the voice en
fait tout le monde s'en fout des
gagnants c'est puis un accélérateur de
carrière ils font plus rien après
est ce que vous êtes capable de me citer
le gagnant de la dernière saison il a
fait quoi depuis rien d'ailleurs bien
voilà ainsi damé l'avoir comme angie tu
savais pas gagné moi j'avais loi n'a pas
gagné non j'y ai gagné dans un instant
ce qui est plus grosse arnaque de ces
quinze dernières années
moi j'adore the voice mais j'ai trouvé
qu'ils avaient quand même un type
bizarre et moi j'étais timothy ça et
j'ai trouvé que c'était bizarre parce
que d'abord ceux qui on chante en
français dès la première sortie ils ont
été avantagés
jim est marqué et je sais pas pourquoi
on a mis à cyprien et aboutissent à des
gospels autour d'eux ils ont chanté en
anglais on dit qu'on avait l'intention
qu'il avait besoin de béquilles qui
n'était pas ils n'étaient pas forcément
dans la dans la performance des choix
non voilée de l'émotion il n'hésitait
pas à qualifier justement deuxième parce
que je pense que justement ça leur a
enlevé de l'émotion de l'hivernale
seulement la production voulait que jim
bauer et margot aille en finale
hall alias et la réception et la
production voulait mais oui mais
j'adorais quand il assumera les bonnes
infos nadon mois dans le tour dans les
analyses il est chiant autant dans les
infos les bois dans la semaine je savais
que margot allait gagner par exemple
pourquoi je les vois les années à venir
pourquoi pourquoi elle a gagné parce que
la production c'est que jean bauer n'a
pas besoin de victoires pour venir un
artiste c'est pas la prison c'est déjà
fait alors pour margot il voulait une
famille l'ont eue at il après on dit
s'il gagne opale va être oublié tout de
suite et lui donner sa chance à
certaines il nous a dit comment ça se
passait avec les bonnes étoiles
car est quand on arrête quand on veut
aussi nommer benjamin ça fait 20 ans
qu'il a pas fait de télé ça s'est
vraiment bien passé
fermeture de la fha millions d'autres
aiment encore il ya deux semaines
[Musique]
pour une fois cette année j'ai voté les
photos j'ai systématiquement voté pour
john gore et personne n'a dit qu'il
fallait voter pour demba ba va bien tu
as perdu tu ira donc à la paire du jorat
d'aimargues elle a une très belle
histoire malgré tout élevé de madagascar
a laissé cinq fois ne participe à la
cinquième fois et elle est au chômage
parce qu'à travailler au futuroscope de
poitiers elle est en cdd dont elle a été
dégagée à belvis mais je trouve quand
même une belle histoire whisky vous -
the voice sam a perdu après la deuxième
reddition sans balai quoi bah en fait ce
que j'avais en moi et j'ai été étonné
que ça fasse autant mais je pense qu'il
y avait rien d'autre à 2 1
il y avait le confinement cette saison
aux 5,5 avec ait un vrai bon film en est
physiquement et il y avait les faits
aussi via un code des savates pas les
négliger la nouveauté des procédés
battle en fait c'est trop long c'est
chiant
alors moi je suis plutôt nouvelle star
parce qu au moins y avait des rires il y
avait les casseroles y avait tout le
monde vous rigolez mais c'est mort je
suis pas d'accord oui moi et moi non
n'oubliez pas le jury parce que c'est le
jury aussi que les yeux lui qui tient
les médias sur moi je n'ai rien à redire
sur chacun des quatre membres du jury
parce que je les ai tous trouvés dans
leur registre formidable c'est à dire
marc lavoine le pleureur au magnifique
amel bent la rigolote sympathique
vianney qui était tout le temps sur sa
chaise il savait se passer ce soir
florent ma vie le de rectitude donc
chacun dans ce monde dans son registre
moi j'ai trouvé tous les quatre
formidable il fait un tollé quand même
le score de la finale est pas mal mais
souvenez-vous les émissions avant
c'était pas où c'est aux alentours des 4
millions sur ce vol et rappelez vous
qu'il ya six ans ça faisait dix millions
c'est à dire maintenant ça sur dix
minutes de plus alors les chéri justin
d'arc à l'événement samedi dans the
voice c'était la prestation du genji que
j'adore un hacker de la saison 3 en 2014
cette occasion la chaîne a voulu faire
une prouesse technologique en le faisant
chanter grâce à un hologramme
ils n'ont pas arrêté bande le truc
jusqu'au bout mais à l'arrivée c'est
archi ripoux vous allez voir en plus la
dar k c'est qu'ils amènent un hologramme
c'est pas le gars il est il est idéal
los angeles le gars il est dans les
coulisses il serait refait le venir lui
tu déchire non mais ça rigolait sur les
réseaux sociaux il ya eu les vannes
exceptionnelle et non mais qui a eu
cette idée super gênante
kenji après le vaccin mais franchement
c'est une farce mais pourquoi ils ont
fait ça pourquoi regardez regardez
kenji gerra que nous a également préparé
une petite surprise vous allez voir ne
ratez pas ça c'est une première en
france c'est assez spectaculaire on l'a
jamais fait dans le noyau moi j'avais
jamais vu ça c'est au top
évidemment en plomb
pour le sommet
c'était une première
c'est impressionnant
franchement bravo bravo c'était dolan
[Applaudissements]
j'autorise internet amer en plus c'est
qu'elle ours blanc du réalisateur où
justement on voyait plus il n'y avait
rien on y vient et qu'il était tout seul
donc là le réalisateur a complètement
raté les planches que vous même le
gramme de mélenchon était mieux ajuster
bien on a vu une prestation regarder ce
n'est pas la seule regardez maintenant
me suis radio
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant à paris c'est
impressionnant et j'avais franchement
pourquoi ils ont fait ça mais c'est le
truc le plus ripoux de mon rêve c'est la
grande mode du moment ils ont gagné
assez d'argent donc c'est complètement
arrêté puis surtout il raconte pas
d'histoires autour de ça ils auraient dû
faire un artiste mort il aurait dû
mettre michael jackson ça c'est un ton
grave mais la banque ngic et dont les
studios ça n'a aucun sens la grèce
attendu ça a été dans le studio c'est
sale et abc d'arc à mettre mmm
quenneville ont fait ça avant ils
étaient très contents quand on lui a
proposé lundi génial je suis très
heureux parce que je sors d'un bonheur
voilà c'est un amour mais il n'avait pas
vu le rendu est donc il s'en n'est pas
il n'a pas su il n'a pas eu le rendu
sait quelque chose
alors il ya eu oui je le gardais les
mains qu'il a non mais vraiment rien de
regarder les mains sont 10 fois elles
sont ignorés on dirait un truc cheap
si l'on prend plaisir à samedi soir ne
me dites pas que quelqu'un à aimer gags
magic tricks et fm et bras mais moi moi
moi la raison j'ai connu je lis ndar cas
ils vont nous dire alerte l'arca non
mais ça rigolait oui
et personne n'a rien vu en plateau en
plus ça coûte cette merde à saku tout ça
doit coûter 150 mille euros mais la
raison cent cinquante mille euros se
sont fait berner ses dépositions
il y en a quatre chez lui oui c'était ma
nes tv c'était pathétique en plus
enlevée de l'émotion parce que c'est
censé être une belle chanson et donc les
quatre là été plantés en train de
regarder un truc qui n'existaient pas
enfin c'était vraiment claqué du début
jusqu'à la fin
alors vous avez aussi pour la finale de
cette saison 10 tf1 a sorti les moyens
en rappelant notamment les anciens
candidats aussi emblématique du coup il
y avait loué je vole 2000 presse n'avait
pas gagné à luan et qui a été
malheureusement la cible de grossophobie
sur les réseaux sociaux s'est contenté
de répondre d'un simple jeu même quand
même sur twitter à la suite de
l'émission c'est vrai que ça a été ça a
été violent
ça c'est inadmissible bah oui mais ce
n'est pas la première fois qu'elle est
harcelée comme ça sur les réseaux
franchement c'est pathétique c'est
affreux les gens sont méchants ils sont
anonymes ils ont des pseudonymes des
pseudonymes et un ciel gratuitement ils
sont formatés cc c'est horrible voilà il
ya plein de gamines en plus qui
s'identifient à luan a appris qu'ils
sont complexés parce qu'elle est le
modèle de plein plein de gamine est
vraiment c'est assez insupportable et
surtout bravo à les aime pour sa réponse
conick simple sobre je m'aime aimez-vous
quoi c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'est
bien oui c'est ça qui est honteux sur
les réseaux sociaux parce que la loi
n'est les biens mentouri à la l1
qu'alain caractère adapté à ça mais
imaginez toutes les personnes inconnues
qui n'ont pas cette force de caractère
et qui reçoivent ce genre d' insulte
c'est juste honteux les réseaux sociaux
pour ça c'est vraiment de la merde alors
il ya eu un autre truc aussi qui a fait
polémique c'est karine ferri l'appauvrir
in avec qui on sait où s'est réconcilié
terminant ce pas on s'est parlé derrière
il ya quelques mois et c'est vrai que
franchement c'est que c'était là durant
120 gr c'est pas la peine de la maison
la mère de l'annoncé honteux c'est léger
accent avoir une caution genre on a
gardé karine c'est honteux
franchement je sais pas ce que vous en
avez pensé regardez bonsoir à toutes et
à tous
bonsoir karine ou encore nikos bonsoir à
tous ce soir c'est le grand soir est
telle aventure
on accueille les coachs allez c'est
parti
bachar karine quelle histoire nous avons
partagé encore cette année
exactement il s'en est passé des choses
sur scène mais il s'est passé également
beaucoup de choses en dehors de la scène
karine ferri oui il arrivé à vous des
biens je récupère le peignoir
si vous voulez j'appelle karine ferri
sur scène
merci de prendre place les amis voilà
c'est vous qui allez remettre le trophée
au gagnant de service en 2020
[Applaudissements]
donnons un vrai laconique
franchement je vous dise c'est pas
karine ferri qui fait aux boys et c'est
peut-être un petit message parce qu'elle
porte des fleurs sur sa robe et elle
fait vraiment trop de fleurs de quoi
elle et elle est présente combien de
temps de mettre une animatrice moi je
trouve que c'est injuste pour elle parce
qu'elle est magnifique et je vois pas en
quoi elle fait mal son travail elle
était juste rayonnante et en plus il ya
eu un coup de massue au monde et vers la
fin parce qu'il me l'a lui a dit j'ai
pas l'honneur de vous connaître elle ne
la connaissais absolument pas et quand
c'est la preuve d'adressé vrai que ça la
fout mal
donc toutes les personnes ça tu amènes à
la moquerie c'est nul
franchement c'est honteux je trouve que
c'est une toute la part de chaque
automne non mais toujours les duos
extrêmement difficile mais bon déjà
c'est un lieu où justement mais c'est
extrêmement difficile et là c'est une
caution pour tf1 bien sûr elle peut dire
que deux trois mots elle y est pour rien
la pause elle devrait arrêter
d'elle-même non mais sauf que nous on
veut pas que là les chaînes féminise les
antennes de cette manière là c'est
irrespectueux pour les verserait d'une
parité comme ça on va même jeu criminels
sont positifs comme ça frérot pour une à
la main d'oeuvre est à la hauteur du
rendez vous par rapport à la fim
d'estuaire dénoncé une humiliation et
franchement j'ai trouvé que nikos
n'était pas sympa non plus parce qu'il
aurait pu lui dire bah non c'est vous
faire les accords je trouve qu'il la
casse est encore plus dont on sait
qu'ils veulent écarter mais qu'il les
cartes officiellement 2010
aujourd'hui l'ue à relire ici les cartes
et va trouver du travail ailleurs penser
à mon avis la sorte lors ils sont en
train de ressortir à oui on parle à mes
proches la douleur mais je les trouvais
magnifique mais oui je fédéral et
surtout pour être si normalement de lui
donner ce status as any cause de lui
donner la parole mais même s'il a pas
envie de le faire et devraient faire
semblant pour plaire aussi aux gens et
moi il a dès lors elle a fait son métier
il voulait la boyer on va regarder
oui 33 pour son nom à 65
je pense que l'année prochaine pour ce
faire être compliqué par british un
petit peu d'accord avec les
téléspectateurs